all right people this is a there's a weird one
this is a weird one this is really weird thanks
to that like button by the way if you clicked
on this video you might have heard i want to
share thoughts my first thought is somewhere
out there paul dano's riddler is very upset
this is not how he's supposed no more
lies spider-man supposed to be in morbius
if this is the multiverse do not lie guys if you
haven't heard yet um there's some things that
came out about morbius and we don't really talk
about leaks anymore on this channel some of you
have noticed and it's not really a leak in my
opinion this is talking about things that are
not in the movie itself apparently anti-leak so
this is not confirmed yet however all over social
media like all over my twitter feed all over my
instagram feed this was just populating my sphere
now i'm like you know what i do want to kind of
talk about it a little bit so if you haven't heard
what's being reported right now keep this in mind
i'm actually still looking forward to this movie
i'm looking forward to morbius regardless of this
information but i do have some particular feelings
about the marketing of how this is all being
handled everything that generated the biggest
amount of hype for this movie no matter what you
were most looking forward to no matter what you
were most anticipating it's objective the thing
people got most amped about were the spider-man
tie-ins as you saw in the trailer first images
that came out was jared leto walking and then
behind him was that photo of spider-man from the
ps4 game the tobin maguire said it's a murderer
on it also you know like the daily bugle newspaper
the oscar building horizon i am i know reportedly
none of these things are actually in the movie
anymore they've all been edited out of the film
and then on top of that too and this one strikes
me as though that's the oddest one of them all
apparently vultures been removed from the movie as
well this is a slight spoiler i personally don't
know any of the details about what the scenes
entail reportedly that there's they're supposed
to just be a post-credits scene featuring vulture
and that's it like there are scenes in the trailer
room like that must be just straight up removed
like the first thing we ever saw a vulture in
the trailer like that must not be in there because
it wouldn't looks like it wouldn't make sense for
a post-credits scene for for that to be there so
maybe the thing in the new trailer is what it is
i don't know but then again sony's doing that
thing where they're showing their post credit
scenes in the trailer that's just strange that's
really really strange there's more to talk about
on this as it stands when i first heard about
this my first reaction is people are gonna get
really upset about that it's one thing to like
manipulate footage in like a marvel trailer or
something like that as we've seen time and time
again now where the cgi swap out like certain
characters one of the most famous moments is of
course when captain america and hulk are running
in that avengers infinity war moment something
that's just not featured in the movie at all
but you still get like captain america and hulk
in the movie that context of that shot is still
happening around that scene whereas in this this
is the thing that they obviously use to generate
hype this is the thing that they obviously used to
reel people in especially coming off of the heels
of spiderman no way home which was all about
multiversal crossover and whatnot and to have
the audience is believing that this is what it's
going to be continuing in this is what it's going
to be tying into some more and the thing that
generated the most hype for this movie at the
end of the day is people going like which universe
does this take place in a lot of speculation a lot
of questions to which we're just not gonna get any
answers about it whatsoever so for people who are
annoyed by it i understand because a part of me
went that was dumb if this is true that's dumb
yeah it's very it is manipulative because it's not
the same thing as just cgi replacement stuff in
like a marvel trailer or removing something this
is a a specific element that generated questions
that we wanted answers to we wanted to see how it
tied in now in my opinion if this is indeed true
it's better that this came out now versus people
going to like some people are not going to learn
this information but it's better that it came out
now so that way people aren't as disappointed and
can just take in the movie morbius so there's
not a riot at the theater yeah exactly because
the people are going to be upset by it i do think
that these marvel movies should be more focused on
just what it's standalone pieces especially upon
an introductory character like part of the joke
around this movie is people mainly seem excited
to see it just to see what the spider-man tie-ins
are i know that's not everybody including myself
like i wanted i just wanted to see a cool vampire
b movie like that's what i wanted to see as it
stands i think this is a bit of a manipulative
tactic it seems like sony's spider-man universe
has been trying to follow in the marvel cinematic
universe footsteps and is just not fully meeting
that anywhere near and then i've they've even
tried it now with their marketing and i'm like
oh no that's how you do it well yeah and what
confuses me is that the reports around spider-man
know way home was that sony was largely in charge
of that marketing and they demonstrated a
reasonably conscientious approach to what
to tease from the multiverse what to keep a secret
and this makes me wonder about the notion of false
advertising moving forward it seems like they're
creating a completely other layer of plot and
world building that's just not gonna appear and i
feel like that is a little bit different because
when you're misleading us with either you know
taking out characters we know will be there or you
know adding characters who will still appear you
know doing something that's not going to actually
be a part of your movie and it might be a part
of one of your plans moving forward is actually
deceptive and might lead people to going i came
in expecting something to do with spider-man and
it's not even here what gives sony yeah it's not
even clear apparently who which like adrian tombs
this is it's like the rumor is is that this
movie is its own universe that it's not even
tied in like andrew garfield or toby mcguire's
or tom hollands that it's its own universe i
feel like part of what adds to that rumor too is
like recently director daniel espinoza pull up the
quote here says so in almost all verses you have
spider-man or a fantastic four or tony stark or
morbius but they will be different in tone that's
not quite the way that the mcu is approaching the
idea but the remaining to some core truth then you
have the second kind of legend which is about the
totem which is that in all universe there's
a spider-man totem which means that in all
universes there has to be a spider-man or a spider
woman so what he's saying here is that whatever
universe morbius inhabits has his own spider-man
apparently and he's technically in the movie
because of that and yeah technically so i imagine
that down they sony would obviously have plans
like the rumor of building up to a sinister six
and you would probably have more bass and craving
the hunter and what i guess is vulture would
also be in there as well maybe alongside venom so
they want them to eventually cross paths with
spider-man or a spider-man at some point it's
just the the plan moving here is just doesn't seem
to quite be working like even for the fact that
venom let there be carnage came out and one of the
biggest things that was most hyped about was the
post-credits scene for venom finally gonna be able
to cross paths with tom holland and then as you
guys saw in spider-man no way home it amounted to
nothing other than like let's leave a bit of the
goo over there and that's it like that's that's
all it amounted to they don't actually cross paths
so it's a letdown in terms of what they're doing
to build hype for spider-man crossover with these
characters i'm like come on these are characters
who derive from the spider-man world they start
off as antagonists for spider-man we have to have
some clear path that the audience can get clued in
on so maybe with the madame webb movie is kind
of what i'm imagining is that they're building
up their own like multiverse of madness in a way
maybe stemming from the madame webb movie itself
which would be cool but then you hear stuff like
what matt smith is saying too about like he came
out recently he was even saying i'm a little bit
confused myself as to even who my character really
is like he's talking about the history of the
character i'll flash the quote on screen he said
like the script was his bible and then there's
this whole history with the comic book but the
movie didn't seem to be doing that and part of him
is just still a little bit lost as to who if he
even is luxurious crowns i'm like oh okay so even
main fight yeah so this whole process just seems
to be uh really becoming messy like i'm looking
forward to craving the hunter because i really
like and admire aaron taylor johnson quite a bit
i imagine that it's it's probably better that the
word gets out on this now versus when they go
to actually see the movie and people feel like
they've been falsely misled or just purely baited
yeah and and like people sue over the stupidest
[ __ ] all the time and i'm like this could lead
to i'm like this is where i'm like no you people
were straight up wide too and if you bought
tickets expecting this you're straight up lied
to in those trailers but all right guys uh what
do you think about this news are you disappointed
in it leave your thoughts down below you can
subscribe click that bell hit that like button
chase gardner spring has sprung and hey your last
name reminds me of growth and foliage and new
beginnings and immortality much like a living
vampire you thrive off the world around you
taking in all the colors and molding them into
your own life force chase follow me on this
rabbit hole of whimsy but hey i hope you're doing
well buddy i hope that you're looking forward to
morbius and not feeling too baited and switched
about the fact that we probably won't get a
spider-man in this movie but no matter what peter
parker's doing i know that chase is always here
and not too far out of mind and i hope that
you're having a nice start to the springtime i
hope you're feeling that spirit of new growth love
you buddy and we'll catch you next month be well
you